was drunk at his inauguration and other
stories this is 40 minutes good evening
I'm Barbara Meade we're going to have an
evening of two barbers tonight vibram
Ian and Barbara Holland I've been a
Barbara Holland watcher for a long time
so I know that we have a very
entertaining evening ahead of us now I
could never oversell Barbara Holland she
has a distinction of being a female
curmudgeon most of the people of the
species tend to be male but she is a
very very special female curmudgeon and
she has a very timely book in this month
of presidential birthdays of an
alternative presidential history I
figured that who else but Barbara
Holland could make up a line like for
President Pierce that he was a hero of
many long fought bottles one of many of
our presidents I think Barbara Holland
will talk for about 20 minutes she'll
take questions and then she'll sign
thanks for coming
hello I thank you all for coming out on
this very sloppy night under orange
alert and I think you're all very brave
and good hahaha and I am afraid that you
have been lured here under false
pretenses I feel that I should say that
the subtitle presidential mischief
morals and malarkey was my publishers
idea and he was hoping that you would
all think there'd be some really spicy
sex stories in here that you hadn't
heard before and I'm sorry to say that
no as a matter of fact I actually debunk
a couple of spicy sex stories and I do
not think that James Buchanan was
homosexual and it is mostly just about
who the president's whereas people and
some of what they did when they were
presidents and I I'm afraid that perhaps
it is also a bit on the frivolous side
and in these solemn times it is very
wrong to be privileged and to speak
disrespectfully of anything in American
history but one reviewer has even called
it silly and it might perhaps be
considered a bit silly in parts and this
to of course is very wrong in this day
and age and other reviewers have
referred to it as a bathroom book and
actually it is a bathroom look and I
don't see why we can't be allowed to
have a bathroom book about American
history if you take Henry Steele
commenter into the bathroom with you and
put him on your knees you'll never stand
up again so it is a fairly light hearted
take but I would like to think that most
of it is true at least I have checked
most of it and I wrote it because in
high school I was bored blue with
American history i SAT there waiting
patiently you had to take American
history before you could take European
history and get to the good stuff with
the heads rolling in the gutters and the
little princess and the towers and all
those things
an American history seemed to consist
entirely of stout gentleman in
three-piece suits who SAT around and
talked about money mostly love tariffs
and taxes and the gold standard and
things like that I am waiting for Marie
Antoinette finally got to her and
decades and decades later I was working
for an advertising agency and our
biggest client decided there was an
election coming up our biggest client
decided that he wanted when a get out
the vote campaign a pro bono thing with
little known facts about the American
presidents so it was a slow day and I
bogeyed over to the library and opened a
books at random and I came across John
Quincy Adams and a tail which all of you
may have heard he was a pioneer fitness
man a long long time it never did a
thing for his figure he was always a row
Ted little fella but every morning he
went out and took a brisk walk along the
Potomac River and then he took off all
his clothes and put them in a pile in
the bank and went for a brisk swim
winter and summer I gather in the
Potomac which I see his party frozen
over at the moment but anyway whether
this was winter or summer I do not know
but turns out there was a lady reporter
this was a long time ago for a lady
reporter and she'd been trying to get an
interview with him and he'd been turning
her down and the counter she actually
did exist her name was Anne royal or
Royale and she was a piece of work
apparently and it does not say anywhere
that she'd been stalking him it just
implies that she was going out also for
a little stroll along the Potomac of the
Potomac in the morning and there is the
bald head of our president above the
waters of the Potomac and there are his
clothes on the bank and she sat down on
them and stayed there until uh he gave
her the interview he didn't have much
choice I have not been able to find the
interview I would love to find
and when I got back to the office it
turned out that the client had changed
his mind and he's not going to do the
campaign after all and I thought well
shoot this is a waste there must be all
sorts of funny stories out there so I
decided to write the book without the
advertising campaign and it has been
very interesting in fact it has been
great fun and you look back over these
43 presidents and you think what a
motley crew you're impossible to imagine
that all these chaps we're actually
doing the same job I don't absolutely
amazing and then you say to yourself all
right who was good and who was bad who
were our great presidents and who are
our terrible presidents you come to the
conclusion that about ninety-eight
percent of it is luck and timing whether
you have voted for a man with experience
and credentials and character and
principles and all those things or not
really doesn't have much to do with it
besides luck and timing and of course
every four years we have an election and
on Wednesday morning half the country
figures that it means the end of
civilization as we know it and the other
half that feels that you're topia is
right around the corner and happy days
you hear I get in there both from of
course it's all luck and timing and all
you can do is keep your fingers crossed
you look at those three lads in the
1860s for instance James Buchanan and a
hep us Andrew Johnson and in between
Abraham Lincoln our great American hero
and Buchanan and Johnson are pretty much
neck and neck for the worst presidents
ever and with our great hero in between
Buchanan didn't stop the civil war from
happening although States went right
ahead and seceded and he didn't stop
them and then Lincoln comes along the
war is all ready to roll so he can't
very well blame him from the war
and then we won depending on which side
of the mason-dixon line you live on we
either won or lost but anyway the war
was successfully concluded and five days
after it was over Lincoln his dead as a
duck and who gets the aftermath poor
Andrew Johnson Oh is well i think really
he's out there wins by a nose for our
worst president ever and one of our
other few presidents to be impeached
though he did squeak by with one vote
and everyone blamed him for
reconstruction it was not his fault he
had radical cover Republicans in
Congress and they were going to punish
the South chill it's kareem there were
many responsible people in Congress who
said that every white male in the south
over the age of fourteen should be
hanged without a trial and no questions
asked Johnson was trying to be as
even-handed and fair as he could but
there was nothing he could do about it
he gets blamed for it buchanan gets been
for the thing started in the first place
and like it is a hero because all i had
was the war he didn't have to deal with
anything else it's all done with luck
and timing so what that is about really
all i can say looking back over all this
it's it is i suppose you might call it a
crapshoot and by and large most of our
presidents have managed to rise to the
occasion we haven't looking back on it
renault had any presents who really
thoroughly dropped the ball mostly we
haven't had any Neville Chamberlain's
most of them have managed to rise to the
occasions as the occasions happened I
mean you take it president who has been
reviled as a draft dodger and hold a
usurper and then well an unfortunate
occurrence happens and he gets to stand
up and become a war leader and pledge to
stamp out evil all over the world
wherever it lurks and bring back kosama
dead or alive and she becomes the hero
which is nice before him because if it
hadn't people might still be
talking about who actually won the
election which would be rather a bore by
now it's been a long long time and
really great to think about her all
looking back is the sheer glorious
variety of it the greatest glory of our
system is its dazzling variety like
snowflakes and fingerprints no two
presidents are exactly alike and most
are totally amazingly different given
our national attention span this is just
as well every 48 years we get somebody
new to watch if we voted for him we
watch to see if he's way to prove us
wrong if we voted against him we watch
to see if he's going to prove us right
we watch his goings out and his comings
in his children his dogs his wife if the
Sun shines and the armies when we cheer
him if the stock market hits the fan and
hurricanes rage we his'n boo if the
times are boring he bores us he's our
national sponge chosen by the people to
absorb the national moods and happenings
he's only a few moves away for the
ancient scapegoat that soaked up our
sins and troubles and then carried the
play into the desert eight years later
at most he disappears into the
wilderness living as cleansed and
righteous and we're ready to watch the
next imagine having to lift listen to
Castro's speeches for 40 years imagine
living in a monarchy if the times are
peaceful and you'll get yourself a young
and healthy king you could be watching
the same first family for 50 years you
would see his children born go to school
grow up and have children of their own
and by then you'd know more about them
you did about your own children His
Majesty's portrait would be hanging on
the classroom walls for generations with
luck he'd get a scrape occasionally
perhaps even have the mistress to keep
you awake for the evening news but
basically it's the same fellow when he
finally dies nobody gets to guess who's
next his eldest son succeeds and you've
been hearing about this Prince for as
long as you can remember and nothing he
does is going to surprise you Americans
would never stand for this even 16 years
of George the third was too much to bear
however an exciting a president maybe
eight years of the same show is plenty
we are not natural monagas monogamous
here Americans pine for fresh fields and
pastures new different clothes in the
White House closets and somebody else to
think about sometimes the process costs
up a hairball sometimes events / pyro a
perfectly decent fellow but the system
gives us chance after chance after
chance and always we keep her eye on the
horizon waiting to see who's next the
founding fathers invented a glorious
game and I think we should go back and
check out everybody's favorite president
Millard Fillmore many people are almost
indifferent to the subject of numbered
Fillmore it's his name they think if
they don't hit in school and Millard he
wouldn't have been a barrel of laughs
but they're just guessing Millard was
his mother's maiden name though I admit
that's a pretty thin excuse and actually
he named his own son milord and I can't
think of any excuse for that he wasn't a
bad man but in fact he was quite nice he
was just wrong a good deal of the time
he couldn't help it the only right thing
he did was be born in a log cabin hmm
see also Jackson Taylor Buchanan lincoln
and garfield cynics believe they were
all born in the same log cabin i rented
out for the purpose too ambitious
mothers buy real estate up from hers
this is probably not true his family was
very poor and indentured him to a wool
Carter and cloths dresser and being
indentured wasn't all the same as being
a Prevost it was much nastier by the
time he finally bought his freedom and
got to school he was a big boy 19 years
old and fell in love with the teacher
they waited for each other for seven
years while he clerked at a law of us
and then set up his own practice it
wasn't what you'd call a classical
education but don't forget he could card
wool of dress cloth too he wasn't
interested in politics until the anti
massage
party came along at the time everyone
got very excited about the Masons and
the anti Masons because a bricklayer
named Morgan had disappeared and some
hysterical type said the Masons had done
him in in the 19th century whenever
anything happened the bystanders got
together and formed a political party
about it for alternate entertainment
they could read the Bible or rub goose
grease into their boots milord went to
this new york state assembly as an aunty
Mason it was the wrong thing to be
naturally everything he did was wrong
presently found himself in Congress and
one day in 1848 the Whigs were looking
around for a vice-presidential type to
run was Taylor and their eyelet on
milord they thought he'd help them carry
New York besides he had nice blue eyes
at a deep voice and was modest and
handsome on a capricorn and what more do
you want her vice president he may look
a bit jolly to you and it's true that if
his weskit were larger it wouldn't
strain it the buttons like that but in
1850 nobody cried shamed for a
middle-aged man who put on a few pounds
or they'd are told him to count his
cholesterol they threw thought it looked
much more dignified than portal pulp
floating around lucid his oversized
suits anyway it was a perfect acceptable
choice who could know Taylor was go to
overdose on cold milk in july of 1850 of
course everybody does remember about
poor unfortunate Zachary Taylor who went
out to the mall to celebrate the fourth
of July and got very hot and sweaty and
came back to the White House and drank
so much cold milk and some people say
cold cherries too and died there were a
lot of different theories about his
death dysentery cholera whatnot and
nobody was quite sure but anyway there
was no I feel more president of the
United States he hit his stride at being
wrong for starters he gave the wrong
answer to the slavery question by this
time there was no right answer loosing
my place he thought slavery was a
terrible idea personally he'd been
indentured that was no picnic either but
he said the states were old enough to
decide for themselves he was a peaceable
fellow and hope to stop the civil war
from happening five hundred thousand
Americans died in it compared to a mere
four hundred thousand in World War two
and it costs around 20 bid
the kind of thing he hated it was also a
mistake to try to enforce the fugitive
slave act under which runaway slaves
were returned to their owners like a
lost earring or the Steinway grand
caught hightail it up the road this was
not only wrong it was impossible another
idea he had was opening up world trade
he sent Commodore Perry to Japan because
everybody here knows about her Club
Pacific overtures and how it gave how
this man gave stephen sondheim the
chance to rhyme Fillmore and still more
presidents film film wars still more
gladdened by means of the heavily armed
frigates Mississippi in Susquehanna that
they buy things from us and the Japanese
hadn't spoken to anyone at all for
hundreds of years they liked it that way
they were perfectly happy alone on their
Island eating sushi and kicking each
other in the ear and having tea
ceremonies sometimes for excitement his
loved ones who tried to poison the
Emperor but mostly life just jogged
along and millard's idea was that with a
little arm-twisting they'd eventually
end up with an island full of Pontiacs
and RCA stereos and Wayne item end up
with a vault full of yen his whole
career was like that when the Japanese
funny said yes we gave them a barrel of
whiskey and a copy of autobahns Birds of
America I expect they were terribly
pleased his other international triumph
was about peruvian guano guano is a
substance deposited by sea birds on
rocks and offshore islands and park
benches and people used it for
fertilizer milord intervene between the
Peruvians and some squabbling American
businessmen I negotiated a treaty so we
could import more guano then everyone
started using miracle-gro instead this
is one of the reasons why the burger
called it silly mrs. Fillmore wasn't
feeling well but she did notice that
there wasn't anything in the house to
read not even a dictionary she'd been a
schoolteacher so she sent word to
Congress that there ought to be some
books around the place and got an
appropriation four sets of Dickinson
Thackeray she still felt lousy but at
least she had something to read I've
been told that she also installed the
first White House bathtub but if so then
what was Van Buren lolling around in a
soup kettle you can't believe everything
you read Miller had his domestic side he
called the White House his temple of
inconveniences and ordered a fancy grape
patented cook stove with all the modern
improvements and valves and flus and
drafts and a clever place to keep the
ashes even that was wrong the cook
ignored it completely went right on
using the open fireplace and getting
ashes in the soup in 1850 to the Whigs
decided milord was the wrong president
or flatly refused to nominate him his
feelings were so hurt that he joined the
know-nothing party a group that claimed
to know nothing about what it was doing
and believed that only people who were
born here and Protestants should be
allowed to vote or get pretty like that
her whole early nice jobs who have any
fun at all he ran for president Minh oh
nothing ticket in 56 and he carried
Maryland he still thought there
shouldn't be any civil war so he
wouldn't support Lincoln so his
remaining friends stopped speaking to
him after that he moved to Buffalo New
York and as far as anyone knows he was
happy as a clam there and nobody noticed
that he was wrong when his wife died he
married a rich widow and got elected the
very first president of the Buffalo
historical society and they thought he
was a perfectly swell president is there
anyone elses anybody else said you would
like to hear about would you write to
hear about poor James Garfield or hey
you know sometimes you get a vice
president that you didn't really mean to
have because you thought he was only
going to be a vice president and she
ends up as president it was many
presidents even if they look perfectly
young and healthy turned out to be
rather fragile and everybody thinks it's
the end of the world but people were
quite hysterical in general when poor
Garfield got shot it was very sad it was
shot in the back he don't even president
for a few months and handsome scholarly
gentleman it was great but cheap and he
had a vice president named Chester
Arthur and Garfield lingered for months
and months all summer long and everybody
was praying hysterically for his life
because they thought Chester Arthur
would mean the end of civilization as we
know it that didn't sometimes things
turn out that other new think nobody
knows that when always what got into
Chester Arthur he'd always been
considered a political bottom-feeder
from the darkest silliest depths and it
seemed perfectly happy that way he was
the contented to love senator Roscoe
Conkling the
man to know if you wanted a job in New
York and never run for public office
since you didn't need to do anything
that strenuous if you're new Roscoe
Conkling Conklin gotchu is one of the
chums that grant shouldn't have taken up
with army life didn't prepare a person
for conflicts Arthur was it even a civil
war veteran like everyone else as
Conklin's friend he'd spent the war cozy
as a worm in an apple being
quartermaster general in New York
besides though we always said he was
born in Vermont rumor had that his
mother on mindful of the future had
strayed over the line into Canada before
she went into labor meaning he couldn't
be President anyway and nobody except
Roscoe Conkling wanted him to be all
summer everyone prayed hysterically for
Garfield's health rutherford b hayes
wrote on his diary that Garfield's death
would be a national calamity Arthur for
president counting the power behind the
throne superior to the throne the nation
referred to Arthur's political origins
is a mess of Filth it was right to these
feelings were hurt he spent 80 days
hanging around waiting and reading the
papers and listening to people pray for
Garfield and maybe he took it to heart
repented he had braids disease too
though he never let on about it and
maybe that helped whatever happened he
turned into an acceptable an honest
president and scarcely gave conkling the
time of day everyone was surprised
especially conflict he was more than
surprised it was beside himself
furthermore he supported the Pendleton
act of 83 which said that people could
take civil service exams for a lot of
jobs and then keep the jobs no matter
who got elected freeing up future
presidents to do something besides
appoint postmasters this made all the
key people perfectly wild with rage
since handing out jobs have been a great
way to make friends and get presents and
votes and surprise the envelopes full of
money and pay folks for favors past and
future as nobody knew better than
Chester Arthur his old friends thought
he had lost his mind Arthur was a
widower his wife more ban his wife Nell
having died the year before he was
considered a handsome dog which supposed
to show how styles change and supported
the most amazing tuffets of grayish
Willie moustachios and side whiskers as
if he'd been trying to eat a sheep
without peeling it
he was also one of our natiahs dressers
since van buren and his New York Taylor
I one of our natiahs dressers since van
buren and his new york taylor had to
hire extra help just to keep up with the
white house orders it's the Rams he
called for 20 coats at a clip the first
thing you did in the White House was
redecorate he called the place of badly
kept barracks and went to live with
Senator Jones and Nevada and sent for
louis comfort tiffany to fix things up
24 wagon loads of leaky cusp adores
battered hair mattresses priceless
antiques and moth-eaten carpets got
hauled off and sold at auction and
Tiffany went to work everything that
could have fringes on it had fringes on
it and everything else was painted gold
as far as the eye could see there was
red velvet and plush and floral
embroidery decorated screens freezes
sconces cabbage rose wallpapers and
enormous painted earns it was simply
gorgeous then he moved in and started
giving the grand as possible dinner
parties at which everyone ate and drank
as much as they can pack in for two or
three hours Arthur's cheeks got quite
rosy and stayed that way one school of
thought calls him a terrible flirt well
another says nonsense he grieved
constantly for his lost wife now the
latter sight as evidenced that he had
the service servants put fresh flowers
daily beside her photograph but i'm not
sure that signifies he had flush fresh
flowers put data on every flat surface
in the house he grew over a hundred
different kinds of roses in the
conservatory and sent to New York for
some truly breathtaking floral
centerpieces for his dinners besides if
he was so faithful and grace trick on
how do you explain pepitas brought her
Pepita who preferred to be described as
a dancing girl was such a dear friend of
the second Lord sack feel that they had
seven children together one of the
daughters Victoria went to Washington to
be her father's hostess at the British
Legation Queen Victoria who wasn't the
prude you think she was said it was all
right with her was all right with
Washington and Washington said it didn't
see anything wrong with the idea Lionel
sackville-west was rather a stick and
Washington felt that anyone who would
improve his parties he was described as
having an unusual power of silence
she was only 19 and a real peach and
charmed everyone including Chester
Arthur according to herself he proposed
and she quote burst out laughing and
said mr. president you have a son older
than me a newer as old as my father just
left her free to marry her cousin the
third Lord sackville and produce Vita
sackville-west and in famous Chum of
Virginia Woolf and all that crowd the
white house issued a formal denial of
the horse whole story as who wouldn't
when Arthur's name was mentioned at the
Republican convention no cheers went up
politico's were still pretty ticked
about the Pendleton act and gun not
getting to pass out jobs and they like
Blaine better anyway Arthur didn't
pursue the matter his Bright's disease
was creeping up on him we now know that
there's no such thing as Bright's
disease but whatever it was it was
creeping up on him and he had a fine
time while it lasted with all that good
food and wine and pretty ladies and
enough coats and suits to last several
lifetimes not to mention the shot he'd
given Roscoe Conkling which must have
been good for many a quiet chuckle under
the sheep's wool anyone else would like
to hear about do what would you write to
hear how Franklin Pierce may or may not
have been drunk when he fell off that
horse that was the hero of many a
well-fought battle is not my line that
was what is M his comrades and arms
called him and he said that he wasn't
wrong but actually his horse reared up
and that they pommel grabbed it in the
groin and naturally faded from the pain
and he fell off the horse and the horse
fell down and broke his leg and the
horse was sober too and that was history
however it is true that when he was in
the White House he did get arrested for
riding over an old lady on horseback and
when the cop realized who he just
stopped he apologized didn't let him go
and he may have been perfectly sober for
all anyone knows but none of our other
presidents have ridden over any old
ladies on horseback any questions yeah
which presidents do you think of going
the furthest in terms of compromising
democratic liberties I remember the
stories about Nixon and wanting to and
how did it Kissinger was concerned about
that he might have a military coup and
one more then had the president's you
can think of mr. and you can include
Nixon too mmm no matter comes and goes
and things do seem to rubber I may never
see aliens and Sedition Act for instance
way back in the beginning they're saying
that you couldn't shoot your mouth off
about the government and we seem to have
gotten back to the First Amendment very
nicely after that and I suppose with
this long overview judge just get the
feeling that just things do tend to work
out in the long run of course at the
moment we're all worried about the short
run but if we could just take a long
view about these things and also
remember not to express any unpatriotic
sentiments in public at the moment
because this is a wartime emergency
that you acquire affection sympathy for
actually along the way most of them
while I was working on them who did I
get to feel except George Washington you
know it's very hard to get to feeling
affectionate about George Washington
there's just something about him that
just doesn't warm the cockles of the
heart so if I could grant I think grant
really really got a bum I don't think he
got rich off any of those scandals in
his administration because he would
simply wasn't that kind of a guy and
everybody else got rich and he got poor
and as for poor Harding there are a lot
of people in here never really wanted to
be President Taft didn't want to be
President Grant didn't want to be
president when Grant was still fighting
the Civil War people came to him and
said you could be President if you want
you can recall yourself with people's
president and grand said I have but one
ambition when this war is over I am
going to go back to Galena Ohio and run
for mayor and if I am elected I am going
to have the sidewalk fixed up between my
house and the depot and then what he's
president poor man I didn't like it he
wasn't very good at it but it was a real
Krabs of a general and yes I think I did
I think I got fondest of grant reading
about it it was a nice nice man and
those scandals were not his fault ain't
even know what they were all about Reno
for money career army yeah naturally
funny are we
naturally funny or witty Clinton Lincoln
no it's true that Lincoln was quoted a
lot of pretty old too Harry jokes
consider the internet wasn't even around
at the time he really knew some old ones
but Lincoln would be pretty funny
because he was an extremely melancholy a
depressed manner I think a lot of the
greatest wits in humorous or melancholy
and depressed though that wouldn't help
for Clinton but then like it was
probably funnier than Clinton know how
easy was it to dig up these gems during
a period when the press was so much more
protective with the president than they
are now uh yes and no there was a long
period when the press was very
protective of the presidents of those of
people who were living in Washington
during the Eisenhower administration
didn't have a clue that maybe was
drinking sherry till noon all morning
and but back in the olden days the the
presidential candidates in the president
I did not say much of anything they let
their supporters do it it would have
been undignified for them for instance
to run for office but man their
supporters really put their backside
they all bought their own newspapers I'm
pretty ready and they call them heavens
they call them bastards and traffickers
with the devil and and traitors and of
course they were making up most of it
and you really have to be rather careful
and touch it with tongues but there was
a lot of interesting dirt out there it
was political though I mean nobody would
after everybody's sex life or anything I
hate if Clinton had been a president
before they invented body wires and
phone taps who would know anything about
his sex life either and besides just
wasn't considered relevant but as for
their political opinions man they pulled
all the stops out
and he has a lot of biographers Morse
Valerie biographers with more time when
I have had to have managed to dig up a
number of little tidbits about you know
how they played with their children and
that sort of thing that if you would
with you people want a lot of letters
there were tons and mountains and
mountains and mountains of letters and
nobler and more patient souls than I
have gone through them and extracted
things from them what about the modern
presidents what kind of information do
you have about them in you book that
that passes it doesn't elsewhere could
there possibly were the tiniest scrap of
information nothin uh I don't think I've
uncovered anything know about it I know
boys unless those of us living in
Washington really thought that president
kenny was faithful to his wife or
anything like that i mean uh there's a
lot of stuff one knew in Washington I
mean even as a child I know that Mamie
Eisenhower drank but you just didn't
this stuff didn't really leak out beyond
the district line very much and let's
see Gerald Ford had a dog named spot but
then I believed Bush has a dog named
spot too and and I had fun watching old
Ronald Reagan movies but no the newer
presidents i'm sure i don't really have
anything here that's good to startle any
Washingtonians yeah go back and tell us
a little about mr. Buchanan his quote
sex life or lack thereof he is widely
considered to be well not widely but by
if the usual we're not considered to
have been homosexual because he was our
only bachelor president now long before
he was president he was engaged to a
very nice girl and they had a fight and
she gave him back his ring and went home
and committed suicide
now there may be made of sturdier types
who wouldn't have paid any attention or
would have gotten over it and gotten
married but apparently he just never
quite recovered from it and he carried
his neck a little funny and a lot of
people were saying that he had tried to
hang himself after she committed suicide
which is not true he carried his neck
funny because he was nearsighted in one
eye and far-sighted in the other eye and
it was the only way he could even try to
focus on you by carrying his neck funny
and and he really really had a lousy row
to hoe and no he was unable to stop the
south from seceding and but as far as I
know his sex life was blameless you
everybody considers that nowadays that
everybody must have some sort of six hot
sex life but if you don't know about it
you must be keeping a deep dark secret
but it may even be that some people just
didn't find it necessary I ask is
because there's been a story around you
may have must have heard of it that he
was living when he was before he became
president he was living with a man who
was a known homosexual I never heard
that no i haven't where'd you get it i
don't even remember but it was here he
was here in Washington uh-huh and he was
apparently living with someone who was a
known homosexual and that's what started
the stories is perfect how come he was a
known homosexual way back then I mean
was he wearing a dress it just wasn't
the kind of thing people talked about
much breakfast maybe Mississippi living
with another bachelor which would saber
is important listen it was not a public
popular subject of conversation and of
course there are always said to be
secret's out there there's Lincoln sex
life for instance which we do not know
about and probably never will his law
partner Honda who wrote his by Lincoln's
biography had it is said had a big fat
folder of say he come right out and said
that Lincoln was one hell of a man for
the ladies and a big fat folder full of
various allegations about Lincoln some
of which may have been true and some of
which may have been
all spent a lot of enemies it was said
that he had had a pre marital relation
with a prostitute which gave him
syphilis and many other things which we
do not know because amazingly enough
herndon did not get a book contract and
did not publish any of this and nobody
knows where these notes got to we just
know that they existed and and that a
few people who had seen them were
horrified and outraged this again and we
only have as a rumor so if anyone here
you know the public has a right to know
all these things and if anyone here
knows where these notes are on Lincoln
sex life in barrage bony i should say oh
eight or ten million from a major
publisher but you want to put it up at
auction write it write a novel yes or
you could just have a novel and very
fine print at the back somewhere and
pretend that you had the actual stuff
have you heard from any of the
president's descendants about the hasta
scandalous information you've been
parties in the book um no I haven't i
want to thank Barbara Holland once again
we learned of a different kind of
American history tonight which is
important we of we know now that what
they taught us in school was not
everything that there was to know of
again if people will help fold the
chairs I Barbara Holland will sit here
and she'll sign and thank you again for
coming Washington DC native Barbara
Holland is a reporter columnist and
author of several books her latest is
held to the Chiefs presidential mischief
morals and malarkey from George W to
George W it's published by permanent
press online at the permanent press com
you